se présentera se présentera pas en
attendant d'annoncer ses intentions
quant à la présidentielle nicolas hulot
présente son livre le défenseur de
l'environnement publie un pacte
écologique à l'adresse des politiques
daniel sportiello laurent fabio par les
temps qui courent il les rend tous vers
le micro est ce que courtisé par la
droite réclamée par une partie de la
gauche nicolas hulot carbure en
attendant la galaxie hulot s'étoffe côté
showbiz
julien clerc pascal obispo ou encore luc
besson pour ne citer qu'eux son message
est très simple
il partira en campagne s'il n'est pas
entendu j'ai entendu ségolène royal dire
hier que ma candidature n'était pas
utile et bien je prends acte de sang
elle me semble inutile à à eux les
candidats de la rendent inutiles mais
d'ores et déjà nicolas hulot fait cinq
propositions concrètes à tous les
candidats avec la création d'un poste de
vice premier ministre pour promouvoir le
développement durable
l'instauration aussi d'une taxe carbone
la réforme des subventions agricoles
pour favoriser une agriculture de
qualité plus de démocratie participative
et enfin la mise en place d'une grande
politique d'éducation nationale à
l'environnement
l'astrophysicien hubert reeves ne dit
pas autre chose
si vous ne vous occupez pas de
l'environnement l'environnement ce que
deux roues est durement et a rapidement
et le frémissement est déjà là laurent
fabius opportunément on ferait bien son
vice premier ministre chargé de
l'écologie
nicolas sarkozy veut le rencontrer parle
déjà de créer un grand ministère chargé
des questions d'environnement
un emballement écolo électorale soudain
pas pour déplaire à l'animateur télé qui
au passage n'a toujours pas levé le
voile sur sa candidature